I like this place I
'm really happy to be able to
live here I love the smiles of everyone who lives here
I don't want to entrust it to you No
matter what Honmakai thinks of this place
I don't know the range
I don't mind if you buy it It
may have been the beginning
But
the time we spent here can't have been the beginning It can't have been the beginning
I spent here  Everything I talked about with you was something I chose myself
So
I haven't lost anything But I
still have a chain I'm holding I
was happy to spend time here
That's why I'm trying to keep that time  I'm going to
pair and list many times now
Thank you so much for the many corn places
w
Kuh
[music]
Air withdrawal Haa
Please be careful not to eat too much sweets
[music]
3 books  It takes an actor to teach
thank you
[music]
goodbye
station
[music]